okay I know it's like a role in our
company and that we have to uh walk on
stage in these things it's pretty
amazing you can borrow it if you want I
know some of you are looking at it
but uh
I do want to be taken seriously a little
bit
all right thank you guys for coming
thank you so much
um Nick couldn't be here he uh had a
personal
um event they had to attend to but I'll
do my best to represent the amazing
story that he put together it's a
wonderful Storyteller if you haven't
seen him talk before you should
definitely try to attend
so uh yeah I'm Tino I am a product
manager spelled d-u-c-k and uh I've been
in data for the past 15 years or so and
I'm here to kind of tell you all about
you know my experiences and kind of my
take on the industry yes I am Shilling
for a vendor so take everything I say
with a grain of salt
and uh you know so as a product manager
if you can say I take you know
requirements from customers and I give
them to engineers
but really I'm more like a data
therapist you know I listen to you know
data customers talk about their data
problems and you know I recommend them
data medicine
so I've seen you know afflictions like
Hadoop
teardata and you know symptoms like out
of memory out of storage failing queries
all these types of things that kind of
uh um you know observed my data you know
uh patients
um experience and so in my past life I
worked on Google bigquery and so I would
recommend on the Google bigquery
medicine with all its wonderful benefits
and things like that generally cured you
know all the illnesses uh but now I'm
working at motherlock I'm one of the
co-founders we're building something
really interesting
um and yeah let's talk about what we're
going to build
or let's talk about what we're going to
talk about here so first let's kind of
uh I want to give you my perspective of
what I've seen in the data industry in
the past 15 years
there's going to be some lukewarm to hot
takes here so please don't get offended
you can find me later we can find it out
um and you know people kind of underrate
you know nobody talks about Hardware I
do want to talk about Hardware because
you know we're all living in a software
stack but Harbor is really the thing
that defines you know what is possible
with software and so there's been some
changes in Hardware in the past 20 years
really and I want to talk about that and
how can we take advantage of this type
of new pattern and finally I want to
maybe kind of put a bug on your ears and
talk about something that's maybe
possible
um you know the next few years like
maybe there's a new uh Horizon coming up
hot Tech number one
is this uh kind of like has the olap
reach kind of like all it's capable of
doing I mean we're living in the
snowflake in bigquery world and everyone
else is just kind of
you know along for the ride but
Snowflake and bigquery have gotten so
good is there what else can they do
right so let's rewind that a little bit
um you know we lived in a world where if
you wanted to do big data you had to do
you know buy a giant refrigerator-sized
Appliance like teradata or extra data
and the teaser you're probably you know
down a couple million dollars minimum
um but really there was change kind of
brewing in in the mid 2000s thanks to
Google and Yahoo and some of the other
um kind of like more modern
um
uh you know e-companies basically and
what really happened was
um what we like to call the declining
value of a single average row so when
you think about it
you know uh what is the world that
represents your house purchase well
that's kind of a lot of money right half
a million dollars no problems in many
areas there's a whole lot more but as
you kind of become more and more modern
the more you think about what's being
stored in the database you get to a
point there you know with the ad click
now we're tracking not only are we just
just going to have Clicks in our
applications and our websites they're
just doing the next steps we actually
want to track those clicks we want to
measure those clicks and at that point
it becomes kind of maybe you don't want
to track that in ltp right it becomes
kind of expensive
and then at some point we said okay
tracking clicks is not enough let's see
if we can incentivize those clicks right
so now we're tracking ad views and now
it's a probability of somebody clicking
on that ad probability that somebody's
going to click on it and go and buy the
thing that you're selling them right
and then after that of course you have
pixels right they're checking everything
then you have real-time bidding right
and that's they're tracking everything
and there's multiple parties everyone's
tracking everything
you can even think about gaming for
example right uh if you look at a Candy
Crush right they have incentives to have
you keep playing and playing and playing
so that you can potentially see more ads
or maybe buy you know the next thing
that they're selling so individual roles
are becoming less and less valuable but
the it's kind of like a paradox because
there's trillions all companies have
been built on harnessing exabytes of
these individual rows right so the in
aggregate they're becoming more and more
valuable and that is really the impetus
behind what we're seeing here which is
you know the the
you know the birth of Big Data basically
right
right so you couldn't really do things
like you know uh tracking uh ad views on
uh before Big Data yeah you have the
tier data and it uses and exit status
but the economics were just not there
right you just couldn't do that it was
too expensive to track these things so
Hadoop was born and uh how many of you
you know have interacted with Hadoop
maybe in the early 2010s yeah so you've
seen right the hype right there were so
many blogs so many articles coming out
we love Hadoop Hadoop is great we put
Hadoop in our you know in our company
and like all problems have been solved
but for every big tech company that had
a hundreds of years working on Hadoop
and made it successful
you had five smaller companies who
didn't necessarily have the luxury of
having that many people work on it they
were really struggling and guess what
those people don't blog about their
failures right nobody wants to talk
about how they fail with Hadoop
um and so you have this hype cycle of
Hadoop uh kind of solving everyone's
problems but the reality is it kind of
was limited right it was still very very
difficult to work with very easy to
misconfigure very difficult to actually
get value out of
and of course ratchet came along
and actually Rachel came along before
you know the the market leaders they
were in 2013 they changed everything all
of a sudden you didn't have to Tinker
with a bunch of Hardware you didn't have
to get an appliance in your data center
you could just spin up a cluster and it
comes up in two hours or so which is
amazing right ratchet changed everything
and then fast forward a couple years
people have to do vacuums people are
running out of space on redshift but
things are kind of adding up uh there's
problems with ratchets so it's better
than anything before it but it couldn't
it could be better and so of course the
query got better so hopefully kind of
started getting momentum and we're
seeing kind of shift to the modern cloud
data warehouse with decouple storage
compute with really high level
availability high level of utility
really easy to use and really powerful
right so that's kind of where we are
today we have snowflake in bigquery that
you know before snowflake could be query
you needed to have a really large really
um strong team of Engineers to make your
big data stack work and with ratchet
with Snowflake and bigquery now anyone
can kind of become a really amazing data
practitioner can store and manage and
get value out of petabytes of data
potentially
right that's kind of the big thing that
Snowflake and bigquery enabled is the
ability for anyone to kind of the tent
got bigger right
the uh the data got democratized as some
people like to say
so
the data warehouses are really pretty
amazing these days like I I know I just
kind of talked about snowflake but the
others are getting better right there's
ratio if there's data breaks there's
other things
um they're all really really great you
know you can't go wrong and they've
solved a lot of really big problems
right they're kind of they're managing
your data for you they're giving you the
ability to kind of elastically scale up
and down right if your things are
getting slower you can just turn that
knob a little bit more right they're
handling unstructured and
semi-structured data which is normally
really really difficult to do anyway
um they work you know they optimize your
workloads behind the scenes like we did
a lot of that in bigquery right if you
have your data
um loaded into the query we do a lot of
work to pre-process it and to
post-process it to fill your workload on
Hadoop
you know you end up in a situation where
you had too many files or maybe you had
files that were too big right then you
have to kind of continuously kind of
figure that out so really the data
warehouse has kind of changed the game
but what what's next right they're kind
of like what can they do that's new
that's different and what we're seeing
really is they're moving laterally into
other areas right like AI real time
they're moving into bi
you know snowflake just announced that
they're moving a little bit into the
five-train category right so they're
kind of expanding their reach into other
non-olap areas and that's kind of what
we see might be the future right is
there anything else that's kind of uh
left uh for snowflake for bigquery for
the data warehouses to innovate on I
don't know it's an open question
I'll take number two
our data warehouses mainframes
so we'll think about this what's a
Mainframe you know if you're I don't
know any of us have interacted with the
Mainframe in the 70s but you're just
going to imagine what that might look
like right you walk into a research lab
and there's this giant thing standing
there and you have to you know you give
a data and you get some data back you uh
have to share with other people right uh
it's kind of like a walled off Garden
you can't really like touch it from the
inside
that kind of sounds a lot like the
current data warehouse right
everything is behind the world of garden
you give a text get back results
right everyone is kind of using the same
thing together right kind of sounds like
a data warehouse a little bit these days
and there's an interesting thing right
SAS vendors building on top of data
warehouse or SAS vendors integrating
with the data warehouse kind of
perpetuating this kind of dynamic right
it's better for everyone to just
integrate with the Mainframe with the
data warehouse
so
what kind of how does this Dynamic led
to
um if you look at you know a typical
application developer right like an
engineer
um they have a lot of luxuries that you
guys that the data practitioners don't
have which is kind of really sad right
I've talked to a number of people here
that kind of wish that this was the case
right like you can have a bunch of your
stack really running a Docker container
right you can do local testing local
build right you can do a lot of things
that are in very very flexible right
that kind of supercharge your
um your productivity in many ways right
whereas as a data practitioner you can't
you can't trust you know you can't test
locally you can't validate your SQL
you know unless you go and you talk to
the data warehouse
right then it's fully SAS right so in
fact many of us here are running several
you know data assassins together and
they're kind of like slap together and
you have to manage them all right
so it's kind of you know it's they give
yourself some credit right this is not
an easy situation to work around
application developers have a whole lot
more flexibility to do their jobs
but it doesn't have to be the case
that's really right when you think about
all the things you have to do to do your
jobs and the lack of flexibility like
your your brain explodes right your
career in data warehouse is like you
know this is like the old ad from the
90s right
the other thing that's happened right in
2010 if you were working on Big Data you
were probably an engineer you're
probably a Java programmer right or
maybe you have some SRE chops you kind
of knew what distributed systems are
doing you knew the cost of Shuffle and
overflow rather like little map big
reduce
uh big Shuffle little reduced right you
have to know these things
um so it's a very low level job right
you actually had to like write code
write your own tools in many ways
fast forward to today and this is no
offense this is what's happening right
um folks today are choosing to buy SAS
right because it's very powerful it's
very provides a very high level of
utility instead of building it so again
like your modern data stack looks like
three to seven different you know SAS
vendors shrunk together
and when you start thinking about it
that kind of looks like a DBA from 20
years ago which is not a bad thing right
things have really become so easy and so
abstracted away you know the the
application uh developer world has been
promising no code low code for a long
time but it's actually happening in the
data world
right all you need to know is SQL and a
little bit of DBT and you can do
anything
really so the tent got a lot bigger
there's a small barrier to entry into
becoming a data practitioner a massive
scale
right so things that like out you know
Yahoo and Amazon and Google had to do 10
years ago to get a large scale any one
of us can do that really it's pretty
amazing
but there's a problem right and I'm not
talking about the lull you know the duck
builds I'm talking about cost right and
and there's kind of some whisperings
around here not everyone's impacted but
we're seeing this Dynamic become more
and more important right so this is a
chart of interest rates over the past 15
years or so right and things have kind
of changed the last couple of years or
so things are a little bit different
um and uh that's kind of impacting
um most of our businesses from a lot of
businesses are now a little bit more
cost sensitive right the interest rates
are going up there's a squeeze you have
to think about cost you have to be a
little bit more responsible
organizations that were growing 10x year
over year are kind of slowing down as
well when you grow in 10x year over year
the data teams are just trying to keep
up right they're just you know they
don't have the luxury of putting DVT on
anything right they're just trying to
keep up to make sure that
um like people who need data get the
value right and of course costs are
going up but when the conditions change
when the businesses are slowing down all
of a sudden you do have to kind of think
about data you have to go back and clean
up this like sprawling data real estate
so the proposal I make is that
self-service bi
with access to Raw data it's actually a
low interest rate phenomenon and it's
going away right because there's a
squeeze on that
so why right why are the costs becoming
um out of control you know uh Frank
slutman CEO of snowflake
goes to MSNBC and says we have this
amazing metric net retention it's 170
year over year that means that on
average a snowflake customer their bill
is almost doubling every year right
right and this is fantastic for
Snowflake and it's fantastic for people
who are growing and they don't care
about cost but for a lot of people it's
changing so why right
well for one
if you can scale but if you have a cloud
data warehouse you can just continue to
scale up and down right you can just
keep going up and you don't have to
worry about that
of course if you look at any of your you
know bi tools or ETL tools
um they're all kind of favoring creating
more and more when was the last time a
tool actually asked you to delete some
stuff right hey this dashboard is not
being used can you delete it that now
it's just all about creating more and
more stuff
the other thing I want to say is the
political economy of analytical teams
you know the further you are from like
the core developer in your organization
the less you kind of have to like
just kind of service them right the less
you have to listen to what they're
saying and if there's demand for data
you just have to you know you know kind
of have the the supply meet the demand
for data right you don't necessarily
have a choice to do that so you you know
with the knob that you have is more
utilization which turns into more cost
and the final thing is you know people
who are creating the dashboards or
people who are creating DBT models
they don't necessarily know how much it
costs to do all this stuff it's just
going to help us for them right the
people who are paying the bill or who
are measuring utilization to make sure
it's efficient are almost never the same
people who are actually doing the
spending
so the bills are going up
and so I have a proposition right the
modern data stack because it's so good
solo code so abstracted away it's
turning all of us into Data consumers
we're just consuming consuming consuming
consuming I mean the you know DVT is a
great example of that right they favor
like blowing away the whole table
instead of doing kind of like
incremental updates right that seems
inefficient
of course we
um recently had the law school Gordon uh
more which is you know he was a legend
or in our uh
in our field
um so let's kind of talk about the
impact of uh Moore's Law and what's
happening in Analytics
um you know thanks to you know that
pattern and things are changing also if
you don't know Moore's law was um maybe
in late 80s I don't remember exactly
when
um but basically it said that every two
years compute capacity doubles like you
know in the visual CPU capacity it
doubles every two years or frequency
right
um but that's kind of changed in the
last uh 20 years or so right I think
it's a little bit different I've kind of
stagnated
um so let's talk about that this
definitely has an impact on on what
we're doing in analytics today a little
bit of context here um you know this is
kind of like a performance pyramid I
would say right the further up you go to
uh uh to the top of the pyramid the
faster things are but it's all kind of
cascading up and down and Innovation
that any one of those layers of the
stack can have massive impact on our
industry and of course all app workloads
are primarily i o bound right they're
doing a lot of IO a lot of reads very
heavy sequential reads as opposed to
like random access we're not doing Point
lookups right we're doing scans
basically
so
the stupid systems came around about 20
years ago we talked about Hadoop talked
about mapreduce why was that uh why you
know why did that happen
oh for one
um if you wanted you know a four core
machine with eight gigs of RAM it was
going to cost you much more than four
times a machine that's uh four times
smaller right if you wanted to scale up
it was going to cost you exponentially
more right so the again the cost Factor
was was really prevalent and if you
wanted to shrink thousands of machines
together
um it was going to get it really really
expensive
that's one that number two is you know
we lived in the appliances World
um commercial database is really
expensive and if you could use something
open source struck together you could
save a lot of money and you don't have
to behold them to uh you know to this
commercial database vendors
there's some other technical reasons
right but you could leverage you know
compounded storage compound or compute
as well right you can paralyze workloads
you can parallelize storage paralyze
reads and things like that but
distributed processing is not a net uh
you know strictly better it is less
efficient than scale up right because
you have to move bits around back and
forth you have to do things like Shuffle
you have to account for things like data
skew data kernelity joins became really
really complicated things like
concurrency becomes really really
complicated and also engineer
productivity gets impacted dramatically
right because you have to account for
all these things when you're building a
distributed system that you don't have
to account for where you're just
building a single node system
so but that's the cost that you know our
industry is paid over the last three
years
so yes this visualization of um Moore's
Law you know when you have the green or
things are doing really really well
right the processor speeds are doubling
basically every two years right 18
months really at the time
but right around the early 2000s we're
seeing that the frequencies of CPUs have
kind of started to stagnate and level
off right so it's becoming again right
you have to go if you want to continue
to to get more and more power out of
your system you have to look for other
ways right you can't just rely on Intel
or AMD giving you better CPUs every 18
months
so people started shoving you know
multiple cores in a single CPU but that
comes at a cost as well because
you have to hydrate those cores with
memory and when you're talking about
DDR3 right when you're talking about the
memories they had 20 years ago
um that becomes that has a really uh you
know a limit right there's almost so
many cores you can pack into a single
CPU before you get diminishing returns
so but there's a lot of other things
that's improved within the course
themselves right The Operators have
gotten more faster right parallel
execution has gotten better there's
caches that are much much bigger l10203
um things are much more intelligent
um on i o as well right there's a lot of
things that are happening networking has
gotten better
um and all of that is improving on the
hardware layer this is a snippet of duct
TB code uh that is just like a an
addition uh operator and if you just
look up what it does it's benefited
dramatically and it's a very simple
operator right then and really the
majority of the things that your
database does are like of that form
right they're not complicated operators
and these things have gotten a whole lot
faster just on the fact that Hardware
gotten better
so this is a chart of uh memory
bandwidth and so and we added like rough
timelines to that you're looking at the
you know recent ddr5 error we're getting
nearly 40 gigabytes per second so now
we're talking about okay if your DDR is
that fast your memory is that fast then
you can have multiple CPUs that are
reading from that memory right now you
can actually benefit from having more
cores more CPUs attached to memory
but never didn't get cheaper right
everything got cheaper
uh but it's still much more expensive
than the you know disk or ssds or
anything like that so you have to be
careful what you do with memory
but if you look at uh
gosh I forgot what the slide was all
about
um but yes if you look at this is the
test that was done on uh on the dram for
the Gravitron I think
um and the the horizontal axis is the
size of the test right so the larger the
the low the further to the right you go
the larger the test
um and so if your your test is larger
you have to fall back on on dram whereas
if your test smaller you can use like L2
cache right so these things are getting
really really fast right we're talking
about 150 gigabytes per second memory
access imagine it's like if you have 150
gigabytes of memory you can read in one
second right that's
pretty phenomenal
and so if you look at Amazon from 10
years ago 2014 or nine years ago and
today what has really changed in terms
of Hardware that's available on Amazon
really not that much when you think
about it right roughly the same cost the
cores have gotten bigger right from 8 to
32 but that's not a huge change right 4X
is nice but it's not massive but what's
really changed is memory speeds right we
went from 50 megabytes to 300 gigabytes
I don't know how many orders of
magnitude that is but it's a lot I know
that
so that's a massive development right
memory just gotten really really good
and then you look at Apple's chips right
the m1s
so this is a unified of one single core
I think
we're talking about 60 gigabytes per
second
but there's some tests that show that
like the more expensive the more
high-end chips are pushing 800 gigabytes
600 gigabytes
I mean that's that's Nvidia right that's
gpus the nicest gpus out there are
probably pushing around 600 gigabytes so
your laptops
if you have a Mac
are pretty darn fast
right if if you're if yeah if you have
things in memory like you can do a lot
with them
and of course George Frazier the CEO of
five Trend we all love them
he did a little test right he put some
data uh on his M1 Pro
and Ransom queries on that using drb
against the you know
um a very popular database or another
Warehouse
and uh it's really really really fast in
fact it's so fast that you see that line
begins below zero so his queries were
taking negative time I think that's how
I read it I might be wrong
so that's kind of it right if if you can
put data on your laptop if your laptop
is something like an M1 Pro
you got a really fast system you can do
a lot at these scales
why else is this happening well let's
talk about the shuffle right this is a
you know typical like a shuffle system
distributed system there's a lot going
on right you when you have a distributed
system you have to move bits around
between different nodes right then
Shuffle typically is like the Sorting of
data between different notes well you
have to serialize the data you have to
deserialize it right you have to move it
you have to transport it somebody who
worked on bigquery which might be the
most distributed analytics database out
there that was really really expensive
right that was always the bottleneck
as you know if we could figure out
shuffle better the query would be
significantly Flash
but if you look at your you know an
in-memory system single node in memory
well
um
Dr B rats out you know for example Dr B
right what's our pre-partitioned subsets
of keys so you can have your different
threads basically pointing at the same
memory space right there's no movement
there's no replication of of memory
there's no movement of memory right you
have multiple cores multiple threads
pointing at the same space and it's in
its memory right at half a terabyte per
second it's pretty fast
and let's take a look at the typical
pattern which is like a broadcast join a
broadcast join is um like a typically a
lookup join where the right side of the
joint is small
it's so small the the you know
distributed system you often copied into
each node you know like um you know map
of ZIP codes for example and so that's
what happens you take the lookup table
T1 and you put it on each node
and now you have three nodes that are
all doing a join together right and then
they kind of unify the results
whereas if you're looking at uh
something that's a single node well you
have three different threads that can
all read against the same memory space
significantly more efficient and
probably significantly faster as well
so
you know all of that's really good but
what are the Dynamics like what are the
practical implications of what I talked
about here so you know a common scenario
that we see here and this is a lot of
text so you don't have to read it but a
lot of organizations start out with just
postgres and of course your application
your website's powered by postgres and
all of a sudden somebody says hey you
know can you give me you know a
dashboard that shows me how many clicks
we had
so you run an analytics dashboard on top
of your postgres database and then at
some point that starts to kind of
overwhelm production so you create a
replica right but at some point the
replica starts to kind of falter right
right so then what happens
so on Google Cloud platform you have
bigquery it scales down really well you
can pay whatever you want
you're good but what about on Amazon
right redshift and stuff like in other
you know vendors they're kind of like
the threshold to uh to start with those
Technologies is fairly high right it
feels like a big leap to go from
postgres to a cloud data warehouse right
in terms of change management as well
right so there's a step missing in the
middle and that's kind of what we're
here to tell you that to be might just
be that step so let's talk more a little
bit of what drb does right
so again lots of text you don't have to
read it
uh but really
Dr B is a database that's very small
the code base is a couple megabytes I
guess it depends on what you're doing
with it depends on what language
um and it's such a small code base
that if you look at the release notes of
drb the Velocity is just incredible
right the things that would take us on
bigquery two years to build
um a tiny drb team of I think maybe 10
people
um are doing multiple things like that
per quarter right and that's because the
code base is so small and so elegant so
extensible right and this thing is also
you can just do pip install and you have
doc TB if you want the latest version
you just do pip update
and of course you can even run in your
browser right you can it compiles into
Watson webassembly which is the same box
that you can put in your browser pretty
phenomenal right sounds pretty good
so it's a small binary right it starts
out really quickly right if you do like
import.qb 50 milliseconds
it's not Java based it's C plus plus
based so the overhead of jdms that are
associated with some of the technologies
that are out there that's just missing
right it's it's a very very efficient
database very low level
if you haven't seen some of the blog
posts
um that drb has released on the tops of
SQL syntax their supports it's really
cool like if you just do like from table
if you don't do select and blah blah
that will be the same as select star
from table right this is just these
little shortcuts like that if you do
like you know a SQL statement and you
say Group by all instead of having to
group by you know this column.com you
just Group by every single column that's
not in the aggregate right the tons of
these little things they were able to do
but otherwise it's basically postgres
right so it's really easy to work with
it's very standard it's incredibly fast
as Jose Fraser has showed us
um and yes you can put it anywhere
that's really cool thing about it we can
run in Python it can run an R you can
run a command line you can run it in a
Lambda you can run it on your cell phone
you can run it in the browser doesn't
matter right
so let's talk about some of the things
that people are doing with Doc TV so for
one it's just so convenient so some
people are taking it and pointing at
some parquet files in S3 right or
they're replacing like uh some other
python libraries with it and saying well
instead of this python library that has
all these you know interesting operators
I'm just going to put induct B in there
and I get SQL right in Python and so
obviously people really like SQL it's
incredibly easy to use and get started
with but also it's really fast and
efficient so just a lot of benefits
those are some of the the things we've
talked about here um there's some of the
things that people are doing with Dr B
are just really fascinating right
because it's so portable the use case is
just popping out that are phenomenal
um one of them that I really like
um is somebody built semantic similarity
right so like
um basically like vector search right
they're able to kind of Port Doug to be
to use these additional uh um you know
for these additional use cases
um I don't know if this person is here I
don't want to mention them but somebody
built a system
that Aggregates and summarizes and
reduces data where data is produced at
the edge at the loggers as opposed to in
your central data warehouse so instead
of BLT that's really really expensive
you get basically free
ETL
he's doing that a massive scale and
saving a ton of money
you have app vendors with analytics
right if you walk around you talk to
some of the more modern bi vendors
almost all of them if not all of them
are using duct to be some form
it's just super easy and free
of course there's a bunch of other
things that are happening right there's
the ecosystem just you know churning out
more and more interesting stuff our good
friend Josh Wills uh wrote a postgres
proxy uh that works with drb right so
now you can have multiple processes
pointing at the same uh database and
it's postgres compliant
so one of the reasons why Dr B is
becoming so interesting is because it's
got an extension model it's basically a
way to write duct TB plugins right if
you want to write new SQL uh functions
or new new file formats or anything like
that or if you wanted to talk to some
service out there you can just write a
Dr B extension
um and so it's simple super easy to do
super powerful and so we're seeing a lot
of these kind of like extensions popping
out here for example uh changshai wrote
a extension for ductibly that's
introducing a whole new format that's
there for like columnar format for
unstructured data right so like from
images and things like that and now you
can do like image similarity things like
that TV
somebody wrote an extension to query
Athena
sounds useful
the other thing that Dr B has launched
recently is the ability to query
postgres so you can just tell Dr hey I
have a postgres database over there can
you query it for me all you have to do
is to do this postgres attach command
and what happens is all of a sudden you
have this other you know you're able to
interrogate your postgres database and
query it and under a lot of conditions
it's faster than postcard scoring
postgres
pretty phenomenal right so that you know
that stepping stone right if you're
using postgres for Analytics
maybe the next step is using ducktb on
postgres for Analytics
this is somebody I met last week
who um built their own drb extension and
they're trying to monetize it as a duck
to be extension for data scientists who
are doing genomic like biometric uh it's
called bioinformatic
um analysis right so they're able to
interrogate genomes they're able to take
this giant genome genome files and
process them turn them into something a
little bit cleaner a little bit more
useful and right that's a whole business
right there right for one specific
industry
so how do you get started with duct TV
incredibly easy right just if you're a
python partitioner pip install you're
done
that's all you have to do and then you
do you know import or include I forget
which one it is uh duct B and you have a
full-blown you know in-memory database
for analytics in your uh process right
it'll speak SQL it speaks data frames
you can create tables you can read S3
and so on and so forth incredibly
powerful
takes 30 seconds to get started with
so mother where do we come in this is
the shill so we are a
an organization that's partnered with
drb we're really good friends we have a
lot of aligned incentives to uh build
duck to be in the cloud serverless Dr B
in the cloud right right some of the
compliments that Dr B usage that
everyone else is doing right so again
like we have a really interesting
Arrangement we're very close partners
so yeah so we're building serverless.2b
here's a really cool thing okay like
rsdk our client is actually Dr B
that's very cool right it's not like we
had to build this all the client no Dr B
is the client so Dr Bean wasm Dr Bean
python that's our client
um and of course we're going to have UI
you know it's like most analytics
services do but yes if you have
programmatic access patterns right if
you have python
that's the way you use it so how does it
work so traditionally with data
warehouses it kind of looks like a
rainframe doesn't it right the red is
like
the service the data warehouse the
Mainframe and you're in the green right
so you send it SQL and you get back rows
here's how Dr B works today right you
have the application drb is embedded in
your application right so you send SQL
to your local process you get back
results locally right sqlite that's kind
of similar to that
here's how mother duck works so we
actually did build an extension as well
right super easy to install so uh we're
there on the right we're the server and
we have storage we have the service
layer we have compute
um and if you're let's say using Us in
Python and Jupiter
um your doctor B is talking to our doc
to be through the extension now this
specific extension that we built kind of
has additional behaviors like a bunch of
SQL that we're introducing specific
that's kind of additionally helpful uh
for example like for sharing like that
doesn't have sharing we're introducing
SQL to do sharing
so there's a that's B on your M1 Pro
is talking to Dr B on Amazon
and what's really interesting is we kind
of strung them together they can do some
really cool stuff together we're calling
it hybrid mode
so how do you get started so this is
just duck to be if you once you go
through a duck to be installation or pip
install once you're using Dr B to in
order to start using mother doc all you
have to do is open MD or dot openmd
that's it once you do that the
motherlock extension gets installed gets
loaded now you're running kind of like
the mother of bits as well in there it's
talking to mother duck uh on on in the
cloud on Amazon right and now I can
start creating databases I can create
tables I can have you know what it says
attach local DB that's actually a
database that's local to uh to the
laptop that I'm attaching to Doc TB so
basically Dr B is kind of you know
working with a local database with local
storage and then I have this table T1
that's actually in the cloud
and I'm can run a drone between them yes
like I can join data that's on your
laptop against data that's in the cloud
pretty cool huh how does it work
well
in your application here you have Dr B
you have the mother Rock extension the
model extension kind of like is is in
the middle of WTB SQL basically right
when uh when SQL gets parsed my mother
comes in and then mother duck extension
starts talking to the model block server
and together mother duck server and your
local you know doc TB and local
extension are trying to figure out in
concert what is the best place what is
the best way to execute a query if the
query is just looking at your local data
on your laptop or the model.s server
doesn't have to do anything if the query
is uh querying S3 for example well it's
better to query S3 generally from Amazon
so mother like server is going to take
over if you need to run a join they can
kind of work together to figure out what
is the best way to do this Joy
so this is a unexplained plan so if you
take a look here in the bottom starting
from the bottom up that's how you read
SQL that down there is a two remote
tables in the cloud that are being
joined so we're going to execute them in
the cloud
and then that third line here is a local
table that gets joined against the cloud
well that looks like the best place to
do it is to execute it locally and then
the first one is is we're creating a
table in remotely so we're going to take
that table the result and we're going to
shove it in the cloud
pretty cool
so the last thing I want to say is
there's a bunch of ways you can do that
one way is that you can Implement your
own cache that's client said super easy
to do
amazing just in time so feel free to
email me so you know mother rock or Nick
at Modoc or both of us
I'm just stealing his content
um and yes thank you guys so much
[Music]